hey man it's me kevin smith we're gonna
look at this clip from chasing amy right
here
um dwight yule um is a phenomenal
performer i met him through joey adams
joey who's friends with parker posey
parker
was friends with dwight and so the day
we met dwight up in new york city
um dwight is an incredibly interesting
engaging
wonderful character and um you know we
we were sitting around talking all day
but i was never
like i'm kevin smith i said i was kevin
but that was about it
so at one point like he was explaining
uh film to me and how films are made
because he worked
with hal heartland i was a huge how
hartley fan so he worked on flirt
so i was just like was hartley like and
he was talking about hartley and he was
like but filmmaking is and he started
explaining the process of making films
and then he goes after he was done he
was like what do you do and i was like
i'm a filmmaker
i made clerks and he like broke down
laughing because he was like i was just
literally explaining to you how film
works and you made [ __ ] clerks
so i fell in love with dwight right away
and i remember me and joey left
and i was like i'm gonna write that guy
into a movie one day
cut to a few months later i wrote him
the part of hooper
in uh chasing amy so this scene here is
hooper's debut
it's out of comic con that was also kind
of
you know groundbreaking for the movies
nobody had showed comic cons and movies
before nobody knew that there were
people that made comic books like a
penciler and an inker stuff like that so
uh nobody had seen a panel at a con here
is uh you know our version of hall h
that was shot at uh the hotel out in
asbury park
i want to say it's the paramount i'm not
sure no that's the theater
i forget what the name of the hotel was
but we shot the comic con there
all the sequences and we shot this
sequence there ben
and affleck and jason lee as holden
mcneil and uh banky edwards
are phenomenal and this is us talking
about comic books and comic book
characters and name checking characters
years before you heard any of these
characters referenced in movies let
alone
had movies made about them and stuff so
uh
check it out man this is the scene from
chasing amy the uh
the the scene at the comic con uh enjoy
uh enjoy and
and uh keep an eye out for
ben affleck and jason lee smirking
because they were
dying throughout this entire process
whenever we were on them
uh shooting they would break and and
[ __ ] i think it's on the chasing amy
dvd you could probably see it and stuff
so check it out there sometimes i had to
use footage that came close to them
cracking
so you'll see them like uh smiling in
some scenes
uh and check this out for years
in this industry whenever an
african-american character hero or
villain was introduced usually
by white artists and writers they got
slapped
with racist names that singled them out
as negroes
now my book
white hate and [ __ ] don't have none of
that [ __ ]
the hero's name is maliqua and he's a
descendant from the black tribe that
established the first society on the
planet while you
european [ __ ] were still hiding
in caves and [ __ ] all terrified of the
sun
he's a strong role model that a young
black reader can look up to
because i'm here to tell you the
chickens is coming home to roost y'all
the black man's no longer going to play
the minstrel in the medium of comics and
sci-fi fantasy we keeping it real
and we gonna get respect by any means
necessary
ah come on that's a bunch of horse [ __ ]
calrissian was a black guy you know you
got to fly the millennium falcon what's
the matter with you
who said that i did lando calrissian is
a positive role model in the realm of
science fiction fantasy
[ __ ] lando calrissian uncle tom [ __ ]
always some white boy gotta invoke the
holy trilogy bust
this those movies are about how the
white man keeps the brother man down
even in a galaxy far far away
check this [ __ ] you got cracker farm boy
luke skywalker nazi poster boy blonde
hair blue eyes
and then you got darth vader the
blackest brother in the galaxy newbie
and god
what's anubian shut the [ __ ] up
now vader he's a spiritual brother down
with the force and all that good [ __ ]
then his cracker skywalker gets his
hands on a lightsaber and the boy
decides he's gonna run the [ __ ]
universe
gets a whole clam of whites together and
they gonna
bust up vader's hood the death star now
what the [ __ ] do you call that
intergalactic civil war gentrification
they gonna drive out the black element
to make the galaxy quote unquote safe
for white folks
and jedi's the most insulting
installment
because vader's beautiful black visage
is solid
when he pulls off his mask to reveal a
feeble
crusty old white man they trying to tell
us
that deep inside we all wants to be
white
well isn't that true
[Music]
[Applause]
hey kids did you like that all these
movies are available on itunes or
netflix in some places
amazon and other places you can find
them they're available
patronize them if you will uh also if
you like this kind of stuff
come on over to that kevin smith club go
to thatkevinsmithclub.com
join up man i do wake and bake three
times a week where i wake up just smoke
weed with you all and stuff
come to that kevin smith club for more
video antics with kevin smith